今天想跟大家聊一個很有意思的案例，台積電。說到台積電，大家都會想到晶片，想到高科技。不過，今天想談的不是技術，而是它的商業模式。
怎麼說呢？台積電的商業模式，不就是幫別人做晶片嗎？這聽起來好像沒什麼特別的，很多工廠不都是這樣嗎？
這就是重點了。你想想看，張忠謀在1987年回台灣創立台積電的時候，那時候的半導體產業是怎麼樣的？
我猜啦，當時一定是那種從頭到尾自己搞定，從設計、製造到銷售都自己來的大公司，像以前的IBM、Intel之類的。
沒錯，那種模式叫做IDM。你必須要有龐大的資金去蓋工廠、做設計，門檻非常高。但張忠謀提出一個出乎意料的做法，他讓台積電「不做設計、不製造自有產品、不與客戶競爭」。
等等，這就奇怪了。一家公司不做設計，不賣自己的產品，還承諾不跟客戶競爭？這聽起來不太像一個追求最大利潤的商業模式啊。會不會只是為了早期吸引客戶的策略？能撐得久嗎？
這點其實就是最特別的地方。原文裡有提到，張忠謀曾經說過一句話：「台積電承諾永遠不會設計晶片，只專注於製造晶片。台積電不與客戶競爭，只要客戶成功，台積電就會成功。」
承諾不跟客戶競爭？這等於是把自己的天花板設低了，因為你不能去搶最大的市場。這樣真的划算嗎？如果是我開店，我肯定會想辦法把服務鏈拉長，增加營收點啊。
其實這就是它的厲害之處。因為台積電選擇專注在晶圓代工，也就是只負責把晶片製造好。這樣一來，那些想設計晶片但沒能力蓋工廠的公司，就可以找台積電合作。
嗯，我好像有點明白了。這樣就像是開了一條新的賽道，讓更多小型公司也能參與進來，因為他們不需要投入巨額資本去蓋廠了。
完全正確。你想想看，高通、輝達、超微這些我們現在耳熟能詳的IC設計公司，還有台灣的聯發科、瑞昱，它們之所以能快速崛起，就是因為台積電提供了這個平台。
這樣看來，台積電並不是限制自己，反而是創造了一個新的生態系，讓整個產業的規模變大了。而且，客戶因為信任台積電不會搶生意，也更願意把最先進的設計交給它。
對啊，這就是張忠謀說的「商業模式的創新最為值錢」。他重新定義了半導體產業的分工，把整個產業的門檻降低了，讓更多公司有機會去創新。
所以，這個案例給我們的啟發是，有時候「有所不為」反而能創造更大的價值？對於一個中小企業主管來說，這代表什麼？是不是要我們放棄一些看起來很有潛力的業務？
我覺得更像是要我們重新思考，公司的核心競爭力到底是什麼。是不是有些事情，我們一直認為必須自己做，但其實外包給專業的夥伴，反而能讓我們更專注，把真正擅長的事情做到極致？
這麼說，對於一個上班族來說，如果套用這個概念，是不是代表我們在工作上也要找到自己的「核心專長」，然後捨棄那些不是自己強項，但又很耗費時間精力的事？
嗯，好像也提醒了我們，在工作和生活中，學會策略性地放下一些東西，或許能讓我們在真正重要的事情上，投入更多，做得更好。